nous n'entendons nous ne voyons jamais
nos enfants à la télévision
ils sont mal dans leur peau mais
personne n'est plus qualifié pour parler
des jeunes et de leur malaise que les
jeunes eux mêmes
alors j'ai demandé un certain nombre
d'entre eux de venir passer une journée
avec moi je les ai écoutés et bien
maintenant vous allez les entendre j'ai
passé cinq ans dans l'armée dans les
sous-marins et quand j'en ai eu huit
très mal parce que ça peut pas durer
c'est pour ça que je vais quitter et que
je suis allé dans les entreprises
malheureusement je me suis rendu compte
très vite que le climat qui régnait dans
les entreprises et de très proche de
celui qui régnèrent l'armée bien pour ça
que j'ai décidé de militer et
politiquement et syndicalement est
essentiel de s'organiser sont tous les
jeunes s'organisent et deviennent
conscients que la transformation de la
saucisse et elle peut se faire c'est pas
du bla bla bla il ya le problème du
conflit de générations c'est grave que
des nos pairs
nous nous engueule bien souvent parce
qu'on fait de la politique etc
ils nous traitent de casseurs beaucoup
de 32 cas servent bien souvent les
casseurs c'est pas ce qu'on croit si ils
nous traitent de cas sérieusement parce
qu'ils veulent pas que ça change eh bien
nous on chargera que ça changerait
j'aurais bien voulu comme beaucoup
d'autres restés dans la région auprès de
la famille parce que on a été élevé là
mais à la sortie du lycée pas de travail
il a bien fallu partir vers les régions
industrialisées
là c'est la vie en foyer où on se trouve
affrontés aux réalités c'est à dire des
salaires de 600 francs et payer pour se
loger et se nourrir 450 francs ou 500
francs dans les entreprises ont subi
diverses pressions quand on veut
s'organiser
là c'est le licenciement
là ces dépressions chez nous ça se passe
différemment on a trouvé une autre
solution on donne de la promotion aux
gens et puma fois ici centre petit à
petit à l'aise et il abandonne cette
conscience collective pour s'en sortir
même ça c'est dangereux maintenant ce
qu'on veut c'est être libre
la liberté c'est d'abord choisir choisir
ça s'emporte ça s'apprend enfants et
après on veut prendre des
responsabilités on va vouloir des
responsabilités et de l'initiative dans
le travail voilà ce qu'on veut sylviane
je suis dessinatrice j'ai quitté l'école
à 17 ans en formation professionnelle
je me sens très mal à l'aise dans cette
société que je considère une humaine et
d'ailleurs je me souviens
je me souviens du mois de mai 68 où les
gens qui occupaient les usines avaient
des contacts beaucoup plus fréquent
s'exprimer plus librement
j'ai 20 ans je suis membre du parti
communiste
13 14 ans j'avais l'intention de
poursuivre des études afin de faire une
carrière scientifique mais j'ai dû vite
y renoncer et dû me mettre à travailler
sans formation professionnelle
tu fais des emplois de bureau où il
suffit d'être bête et discipliné
maintenant je travaille toujours dans
les bureaux j'ai réussi à passer mon bac
par correspondance mais le problème se
pose toujours je dois je voudrais faire
quelque chose
j'ai deux possibilités une bourde qui ne
me permet pas de vivre et bien travail
8h08 heure et demie par jour payer
correctement mais qui ne parlait pas
d'étudier le soir c'est pour ça que je
me suis
inscrits au parti communiste et afin de
lutter pour une société plus juste où
tous les enfants les jeunes auront des
chances d'égal quelle que soit la couche
sociale en question quand tu te sens
tissu jeu 19 ans je suis étudiant à
nanterre droit bon je suis très contente
par la télévision ça nous arrive pas
souvent
j'ai fait la prison parce que pour mes
idées politiques je suis accusé d'avoir
frappé un militant d'occident en prison
j'ai vu la délinquance j'ai vu le
phénomène de la délinquance qu'on
considère comme un phénomène marginal
c'est la pègre et où je pense que les
femmes le phénomène de la délinquance
d'un prison de vitesse étaient les
jeunes de 18 à 21 ans c'est une
délinquance sauvages sont des types qui
n'arrive pas à se réinsérer dans la
société parce qu'ils n'ont pas de but
parce qu'ils ne savent pas où aller et
qu'effectivement parti au moment où on
ne change pas la société appartement ou
ne voient pas la vie différemment
il y aura jamais de véritable
réinsertion la délinquance sera toujours
les prisons ça sera toujours eu plus en
plus de jeunes dans les prisons sa gelée
compris ça m'a confirmé dans mes idées
politiques je 19 ans je noterai lallaing
je préfère sacyr ayari je suis assez
différent de tous les jeunes qui
viennent de s'exprimer parce que je
conteste pas je suis content la
révolution je serais même peut-être
amené à lutter contre la révolution
parce que j'ai choisi de servir la
nation dans l'armée mais ça veut pas
dire que je me sens pas jeune moi aussi
je me sens jeune pleinement parce que
moi aussi je n'accepte pas forcément la
société qu'on nous propose plus d'une
société matérialiste
dénué de sens sans armes et c'est
justement j'ai choisi la vie militaire
c'est précisément parce que pour moi
l'armée est une société très différente
où règne une fraternité d'idéal et au
règne un désintéressement qu'on trouve
nulle part ailleurs dans la nation
marcel breton déplacées dans la région
parisienne
je travaille comme magasinier dans une
entreprise de roulement à lille le
copain qui sont rentrés en même temps
que moi ou après moi sont avancés
normalement dans leur profession moi il
m'a fallu un an pour passer magasinier
et je suis encore magasinier alors que
les chefs directs n'ont rien à me
reprocher et même me confient les
travaux les plus délicats alors je pense
que c'est le fait que je suis délégué
syndical qui nuit à mon avancement et
c'est dommage parce que beaucoup de
jeunes et même des adultes risquent de
reculer devant l'engagement syndical
alors que c'est quelque chose de très
important
claude j'ai 19 ans je travaille dans une
boîte de la région ouest et je suis
militant de navigation révolutionnaire
qui s'appelle vive la révolution
j'ai fait trois en trois ans
d'apprentissage
dans un collège technique et quand j'ai
commencé à bosser en boîte je me suis
rendu compte très vite de la réalité car
ce que c'est a effectivement travaillé
en usine et mon les conditions de
travail justement dans les ateliers tous
et que bon alors partie ce moment là mon
justement j'ai commencé à gueuler
seulement contre ses conditions de
travail qui était bon de lui dans la
gueule les temps les temps sur les
pièces les temps très juste très serré
sur les pièces et on va passer ce moment
là je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait à
des moments où vous voulez lutter on
sortait sans arrêt bon à un appareil
répressif cerdan lusine c'était c'était
les chefs ont quitté leur est toujours
derrière mon cul petits chefs et flic
pour ce que je veux c'est vraiment faire
la révolution pourquoi parce que je
transforme et le transformer le monde
changer les rapports entre les hommes
dont que les gens ne se fasse plus chez
au boulot mais qui est vraiment
participe activement à leur travail
prennent des initiatives aiment leur
boulot ne fasse pas à 8 heures sur une
chaîne mais en face en face en phase 4
ou 6 et que le reste du temps ils
puissent s'épanouir s'amuser prendre
vraiment des vrais loisirs mais pas des
loisirs qu'on leur a inculqué et bon
vraiment vivre et changer la vie quoi
c'est ça un peu que je veux je m'appelle
marc tessier je suis élève de l'ena
avant j'ai fait l'école polytechnique si
j'ai fait c'est les écoles c'était parce
que je voulais servir l'état
en l'état c'est un ensemble de corps
souvent très fermés sur eux-mêmes et
également qui souvent défendre leurs
privilèges
comment s'étonner alors que dans une
école comme l'ena et même dans
l'administration soit l'esprit de
carrière qu ils en portent le plus
souvent sur le sens du service public et
que tous les efforts que nous faisons
pour développer la formation à l'école
et je suis en grande partie à cause de
cela on nous reproche aussi de dt d'être
des technocrates
je pense que c'est une fatalité dans un
état comme le nôtre est dans une société
qui est paternaliste qui et
centralisatrice
je pense comme beaucoup de mes camarades
que si on respecte mieux les libertés
individuelles et politiques que si on
essaye de fonder une véritable
démocratie à tous les niveaux
la participation réelle des citoyens
alors l'action l'administrateur ne sont
pas forcément celles d'un technocrate je
suis agricultrice en vendée comme tous
les garçons et comme toutes les filles
de mon âge je suis je suis allé à
l'école primaire jusqu'à 14 ans et à cet
âge là j'ai dû arrêter mes études et
travailler sur l'exploitation paternelle
j ai travaillé sans percevoir aucun
salaire j ai travaillé tous les jours
dimanches et fêtes c'est le lot 2
de tous les jeunes qui travaillent dans
les exploitations où on a des
productions animales
je suis technicien j'ai 25 ans je
travaille dans un centre de recherche
d'une entreprise privée de cent mille
personnes
lorsque j'ai quitté le lycée avec mes
diplômes dans ma poche je pensais
pouvoir faire une carrière dans
l'industrie est passé ingénieurs alors
je me suis vite aperçu que je ne pouvais
pas entre le technicien à l'ingénieur il
y avait un grand fossé notre société au
début on pouvait avoir des contacts
directs avec le patron actuellement par
un statut différent
notre société a contourné la loi ce qui
fait que maintenant nos sociétés est un
holding étant donné que maintenant ne
pourront plus avoir justement l'accès au
véritable pouvoir de décision
si bien que notre patron s'appelle
réformes et qu'il habiterait aux états
unis ça ne changera absolument rien pour
nous simplement on aura peut-être de
meilleurs salaires
je crois mon métier je laime les mais
pour moi c'est y travailler chaque jour
sans compter mes heures c'est ne pas
savoir ce que sont les congés il croire
pour moi c'est être obligés d'investir
ces êtres obligés d'être à la merci d'un
capital qui m'échappe
c'est de plus en plus me trouver non
plus le maître mais l'objet des capitaux
qui skie kim environnent c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense je ne sais plus
très bien où je suis comme tous mes
camarades et je ne serai plus très bien
ce à quoi je corresponds vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la société
pour nous nous sauver c'est nous mettre
en coopération c'est travailler tous
ensemble
l'exemple que je peux amener le plus
concret est de savoir pour moi même si
demain je ne serais pas obligé de perdre
cet été en que j'aime pour aller comme
tous les autres amis mes autres amis
travailler autre part à une usine ou
travailler dans un bureau
[Musique]